is kayleigh mcinerney before we get to
that between swalwall the bidens in
china
you know maybe a little bit ironic
considering impeachment in russia russia
russia
uh but yet a very different treatment
from a media that you uh i believe know
very well
yeah exactly the fact that they did not
cover this it is journalistic
malpractice to say the absolute least
look you had joe biden in the early
stages of the primary
say that china is not a strategic threat
to this country and we all kind of
raised our eyebrows that he said that
well now we know why because there was
10 for the big guy because there was joe
biden getting involved in the china
funds coming into his family
and the fact that you had a dereliction
of duty in the press to not even cover
this
not even ask a question to jump on this
call it russia disinformation that is
what they called it
while meanwhile they made money they
made big bucks off of
using russia disinformation to go after
this president it is simply remarkable
it should enrage every american and
should certainly enrage the 14
who said they would not have voted for
joe biden had they known this in advance